♪
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN'S HORROR
SHOW ON THE BORDER JUST GOT A
LITTLE MORE GRIZZLY.
ON MONDAY, MORE THAN 50 ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS FOUND DEAD IN A
SWELTERING TRACTOR-TRAILER
ABANDONED NEAR SAN ANTONIO.
THEY WERE PRACTICALLY BAKED
ALIVE IN THE OPPRESSIVE TEXAS
HEAT.
SMUGGLERS TRIED TO COVER UP THE
ROTTING SMELL OF THE DEAD BY
SPRINKLING THEM WITH STEAK
SEASONING.
AND THEN THEY JUST RAN AWAY.
ABANDONING THE FEW PEOPLE WHO
WERE STILL LEFT ALIVE.
THERE WERE CHILDREN IN THAT
TRUCK.
THERE WERE FAMILIES IN THAT
THEY WERE SMUGGLED BY COYOTES
DUE TO JOE BIDEN'S BROKEN
BORDER.
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT LAYS THE
BLAME AT THE FEET OF OUR
PRESIDENT TWEETING THESE DEATHS
ON R. ON BIDEN THEY ARE THE
RESULT OF HIS DEADLY OPEN BORDER
POLICIES SHOW THE DEADLY
CONSEQUENCES OF THE HIS REFUSAL
TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
BUT JOE BIDEN SAYS IT'S NOT HIS
FAULT SAYING THIS:  EXPLOITING
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS FOR
PROFIT IS SHAMEFUL AS IS
POLITICAL GRANDSTANDING AROUND
TRAGEDY.
AND MY ADMINISTRATION WILL
CONTINUE TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO STOP HUMAN SMUGGLERS
AND TRAFFICKERS.
JOE BIDEN IS DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO STOP SMUGGLERS?
KIND OF LIKE HE IS DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO LOWER GAS
PRICES.
WHICH IS NOTHING.
JOINING ME NOW IS TEXAS GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT.
HAS THE WHITE HOUSE CALLED YOU?
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THEM ABOUT
THE MASS CASUALTY EVENT.
>> NO HE HAS NOT.
THE THING THAT STRUCK ME.
HE SAID IS HE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO STOP HUMAN
SMUGGLING.
THAT'S A LIE.
HE HAS STOPPED DOING EVERYTHING
THAT HAD BEEN DONE TO ADDRESS
HUMAN SMUGGLING.
HE HAS DEFUNDED AND INADEQUATELY
FUNDED BORDER PATROL.
HE HAS DISMANTLED ICE.
HE HAS ELIMINATED ALL OF THE
BORDER SECURITY EFFORTS THAT
WERE PUT IN PLACE BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT WAS JUST A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO WHEN WE HAD THE MOST SECURE
BORDER IN DECADES AND TODAY WE
HAVE A WORST HUMAN SMUG IMLING
PROBLEM THAN EVER BEFORE.
THESE PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES, THEY DID SO BECAUSE
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS EMPOWERED
AND EMBOLDENED THE CARTELS TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAW HAPPEN.
IT'S A TRAGEDY AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO STOP UNTIL BIDEN BEGINS
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS PASSED BY
CONGRESS AND THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> Jesse: THE CARTELS ARE
GETTING RICHER THAN THEY EVER
HAVE BEFORE, GOVERNOR, HAVE YOU
HEARD WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE PLAN
IS TO TAKE OUT THE CARTELS?
DO THEY HAVE A PLAN TO GO ON
OFFENSE AGAINST THE CARTELS AND
THE COYOTES?
>> JESSE, THE ONLY THING THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IS EXACTLY WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN CAMPAIGNED ON
WHEN HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
HE WAS QUIZZED DURING THE
DEBATES.
IF IF HE SUPPORTED OPEN BORDERS
AND HE SAID YES.
ALL HE HAS DONE SINCE HE HAS
BEEN PRESIDENT IS EMPLOY OPEN
BORDER POLICIES.
THAT MEANS BASICALLY CEDING THE
BORDER TO THE CARTELS TO ENGAGE
IN ACTIVITY JUST LIKE THIS.
THESE ARE NOT THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE DIED COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THIS IS JUST THE MOST RECENT
EXAMPLE THIS HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME AND CAN YOU SEE THE NUMBERS
SKYROCKET IN THE HOT TEXAS
SUMMER SETTING IN NOW.
IT'S A TRAGEDY WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS DOING.
HE IS KNOWINGLY ALLOWED THIS TO
HAPPEN AS WELL AS WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH REGARD TO THE
INFILTRATION OF ENOUGH FENTANYL
TO KILL EVERY MAN, WOMAN, AND
CHILD IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> Jesse: HOPEFULLY THIS
PRESIDENT CAN BE PUBLICLY SHAMED
INTO DOING SOMETHING MORE THAN
HE IS ALREADY DOING.
WE HAVE OUR FINGERS CROSSED BUT
WE ARE NOT EXPECTING THAT TO